the great unraveling that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now the ruling class in Washington it's
in a flat spin
it's been more than two years now since
Biden took power and yet they have no
success stories to tell
Americans are getting poorer and China
is getting stronger
the economic Outlook we know that's
bleak
and we have a hologram for a president
with a cabinet filled with people that
you wouldn't hire to tutor your fourth
grader in math
President Obama announced that pardon me
President Biden whoa
that is news we think transplants and
Automobiles but uh what about bike
scooters wheelchairs for that matter
so I am the head of the space Council
I love space not sure what our division
of
responsibilities is but let me be clear
title 42 or not the border is not open
the presser co-conspirators and
orchestrating this period of national
decline led by people like you just saw
on those clips
but a seething hatred of Republicans
Trump his voters it drove them to take
the most extreme positions and to
completely abandon their role as
objective checks on power
and yet the Press wonders why people are
tuning them out why their readership is
collapsing
so now the cabal has only a few cards
left to play
number one we exposed last night
the smear and smash campaign to
discredit and ultimately silence all
their critics
the women's group that are going to
spend more than 10 million dollars
online and on television pushing back
against misogynistic and sexist smears
against Kamala Harris it's not hard to
put on a mask just wear a mask you'll
save lives out there if you do but the
record is very clear what we saw for
years and years of Donald Trump being
Putin's puppet
and of course they're going to do
anything they can to change the subject
as if Americans are going to somehow
forget that their retirement savings are
disappearing because the press and the
Democrats dangle some shiny object in
front of us
speaker McCarthy has held a gavel for
less than three months and already
he has done more than any party leader
in Congress to enable the spread of
Donald Trump's big lie I think that's
very dangerous for all of us uh that uh
information has now been revealed what
we have seen from charcoal Carlson is
continued lies from a proven liar what
he is doing with the help of House
Republicans and speaker McCarthy mind
you is dangerous
information is dangerous
but despite all their efforts the truth
is seeping out and it's increasingly
obvious that we're facing potential
disaster on all fronts
in all of it all of it is self-inflicted
by the DC leadership class
our border
what's a gift to the cartels
our Public Schools that's a gift to the
teachers unions and the sexual
propagandists the cities they are a gift
to the criminals illegals and home to
endless despair
our foreign policy well that's obviously
a gift right now to China
and our energy Independence that's a
gift to globalists who want to force
scarcity on America
and our economy
that's not really a gift to anyone it's
in shambles
so president stumbles and his friends on
the hill really did a number on all of
us
personal debt skyrocketing interest
rates going up for the foreseeable
future
and we're headed toward a recession
now maybe this was their plan all along
but now the truth is out
America is getting weaker and Biden's
only answer at this point is to propose
massive tax hikes and then to prepare
Americans for a new new normal
a new America where we lower our
expectations reduce our consumption and
give up our traditional freedoms and
then we learn to be happy with it
it shows in the end that the Democrats
now know that there will be no economic
growth under their policies and that
inflation is just going to drag on
Powell at the fed he's not going to bail
him out
he can't
now we told you recently that the IMF is
predicting a nightmare for our GDP over
the next two years Germany France and
Spain's gdps will outpace Ours by 2024
even Russia's GDP is growing faster than
the United States is
oh and I didn't realize by the way that
build back better meant that real wages
in median household income would drop
under Biden that's his definition of
better
they've given up on America
they've essentially thrown up their
hands on fixing the cities that's just
out of their control
check out this piece by David Graham in
the Atlantic rather than admitting that
their pro-crime pro-tax policies High
tax policies didn't work
they declare that the cities now are
just ungovernable
now just because they've given up on
building a strong and prosperous America
doesn't mean the rest of us should
think about this they are more afraid of
grandmothers who are walking through the
capitol on January 6 then the Communist
Chinese who were poised right now
to take Taiwan
and the same Democrats who won't forgive
Republicans for Donald Trump they're
happy to forgive China for covid they're
happy to forgive China for stealing our
technology they're happy to forgive
China for crushing Hong Kong for
torturing the uyghurs and the list goes
on and on
this tells the real story of how
intellectually bankrupt they all are we
know it and I think they even know it
as the angle has been saying all along
this situation in our country is only
going to change when enough Suburban
women and enough Urban voters in key
states have decided they've had enough
some of them might not like all of them
might not elect Trump for all we know
but I simply don't believe that those
same people want to continue to live
like this and be deceived this way
as the economic Carnage continues to
pile up
as our geopolitical dominance collapses
it's going to become nearly impossible
for even the slickest political
Consultants to spin the Democrats reign
as anything than an utter nightmare
we are witnessing their great unraveling
but let it not be ours and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else